las últimas encuestas dan una ligera
Victoria al candidato izquierdista Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva pero en este
pueblo de Brasil en el Estado de Paraná
tienen una meta convertirse en el
campeón del voto por el ultraderechista
Yair bolso
es una ciudad colonizada por alemanes
gente que valora a la familia el
cristianismo todo esto que predica
nuestro presidente Yair bolsonaro el
apoyo a la agronegocio el apoyo a las
empresas Así que esto hizo que nuestra
gente votara masivamente a bolsonaro
geomet Foster votar macizamente ahí no
hubo solar Y es que la localidad ya votó
masivamente al presidente bolsonaro en
la primera vuelta de los comicios
presidenciales el pasado 2 de octubre
con el 82% de los votos logrando al
segundo porcentaje más alto del país Los
fervientes Seguidores del mandatario
están presionando en las calles para
lograr una victoria aún mayor con una
campaña basada en el miedo frente a su
rival Lula da Silva encontrar un cartel
del partido uno de los trabajadores es
casi Misión Imposible
es el miedo es el miedo que creo que
tienen todas las madres todos los padres
todos los brasileños de tener a sus
hijos en manos del PT porque vemos que
es muy liberal muy liberal está muy
liberado según los servidores del
candidato de extrema derecha bolsonaro
prometió visitar la localidad que más
votos le dé en los comicios de este
domingo y esta región agrícola con
grandes plantaciones de soya está
dispuesta a llevar al mandatario a la
reelección